in this topic of measurement area
perimeter all that kind of thing
there's one big mistake that students do
over and over again I've seen hundreds
and thousands of students make the same
mistake and that's why I'm trying to get
your full attention to emphasize to you
not to make this mistake
he's the mistake students learn how to
calculate the area of a bunch of
different shapes by the end of this
chapter you'll have a good like seven or
eight different formulas different
shapes that you'll know how to calculate
the area on you just put the right
numbers in and then out a constant the
big mistake that many students learn is
they just learn those formulas they just
memorize them seven or eight separate
objects that have nothing to do with
each other
and as a consequence after you stop
using them it's really hard to keep all
of them in your head because you don't
use them anymore
right here's what I want to try and
communicate to you there are not seven
or eight different separate formulas
there's only really one formula and then
we look at it in lots of different
angles let me try and explain we've got
one two three four specific shapes so
we've already worked out formulas for
for their area before this think back to
before composite shapes what was the
simplest kind of shape we looked at it
was a square very good okay beside this
word square can you just drop me a
little square just so we've got a visual
cue and we know oh the area of a square
it's the simplest kind of shape you just
look at it's one dimension it's its
width or its high it's the same number
and then what do you do with that with
that number say it was a square of side
one what would you do it you square it
amazing right this is one of the reasons
why it's so nice and easy to remember so
this is really good
fantastic when we move past the square
we looked at rectangles very good now
the rectangle has its own formula
however this is what I want to get
across to you right the formula was base
times height base times height we looked
at this but all you're really doing is
saying well how many squares how many
squares can I fit inside this rectangle
for example if I divided this up
there we go looks to me like I can fit
12 squares in there right that I count
right 12 12 squares right rather than
just go 1 2 3 4 5 6 9 and 10 11 12 a
much easier way is to just say well I
can fit two rows each of which have 6 in
them two rows are 6 two times six base
times height so you can see it's not
really a whole new formula it's just hey
you know that formula you saw before
just do it a whole bunch of times
what was that the rectangle do you
remember that now you could go one of
two ways it doesn't really matter let's
um the one I heard first was the
triangle now you learnt a new formula
for this right in fact I'm able to start
writing these down we learn s squared
for this one we learn base times height
for this one
now hopefully by this point you've got
the formula in your head what is it it's
base times height on two now that should
look familiar
shouldn't it it's not a whole new
formula it's just when you've got a
triangle like say this okay you can draw
a rectangle around it that has the same
dimensions as this guy
like so and can you see this triangle is
exactly half of that rectangle
you know this bit over here is the same
as this and this bit over here is the
same as that you're just taking half of
it out and you're not interested in that
so that's why this is not a new formula
so much as it's a different way of
looking at the old formula okay now then
I think the shocker I think you said the
last one which was a parallelogram very
good now again we can draw one last one
here here we go here's a parallelogram
does anyone know what the formula for
the parallelogram is it's you go ahead
MA it's somewhat familiar its base but
we go a little more specifically rather
than just seeing base times height we
say base times perpendicular height very
good because we have to make sure we
specify it's like straight up and down
with a right angle
parallelogram might lean over but you
don't use this leaning over distance you
use the straight up and down distance
perpendicular height now just like
before right it looks like it's a
different shape but it's not really you
might remember this from last time look
up for a second in case this is not
familiar to you if you draw this
perpendicular height in here and just
like cut off this triangle bit just cut
it off for a second you got this shape
left over but now I've got this green
triangle in my hand I'm gonna stick it
over here right what shape is that
that's a rectangle right that's why it's
exactly the same base times height it's
just I had to move this over to see it
you see it's not really a different
formula it's just looking at these
different shapes through the lens of
seeing the old shapes that we had okay
how many squares do you see in this
thing how much of a rectangle do you see
in this thing and so on so now and this
time I'd like it a little bit bigger
because we're gonna work on this we're
gonna look at the trapezium now the
trapezium we can come up with a formula
for this but I want to emphasize to you
it's not a new formula it's just these
guys come out from a different angle
okay so drama drove me up please and
you'll need a ruler for this definitely
if you don't have one please show your
hand up draw me up a trapezium what is
the key characteristic of a trapezium
what what does it have it's got one one
pair of parallel sides right one pair of
parallel sides you might even leap even
like to mark them in as parallel and to
work out the area of this thing there
are three numbers that we need just like
all of these ones over here we're gonna
need the height straight up and down
what will we call that again starts with
a P the perpendicular height very good
now just look carefully because I want
us to draw the perpendicular height
somewhere in particular if you've drawn
yours like mine how the top edge is a
bit smaller than the bottom edge then
what I want you to do is go from the
left of this guy here and then draw
straight down so from the left of that
top edge and because this is the
perpendicular height just like we have
been before let's call it H
now in all of the other shapes we were
looking at over here the other thing you
needed was the base and we are going to
mark in the base on this shape like so
beef a base except there's this other
length up the top and it's different
right it's not the same length unlike
with these guys these are all the
opposite links are the same so instead
of calling that top 1b I'm gonna call it
hey a and B this is really important a
and B are the parallel sides okay ah not
yet
we are going to come to a formula and
some of you have encountered it before
there's more important than what the
formula is is where it comes from okay
all right now here's the fun bit just
look up for a second okay I'm going to
issue you all the challenge you know how
I said all this rectangle it's just like
a bunch of squares this triangle it's
just like a part of the rectangle and
this parallelogram it's also like a
rectangle just dressed up differently we
can look at this trapezium through any
one of these three lenses you can turn
this into a rectangle you can do
something a bit like this you can turn
it into a parallelogram as well the one
I'm going to show you is how to find the
triangles then hidden inside so my
challenge to all of you is after we're
done here we have a formula can you find
that formula through either of these
parts instead it's a bit of fun just to
explore and draw and see what happens
but for now let's see there are
triangles hiding in here and one of them
makes it really easy to work out this
formula that everybody is going to tell
us in a second here's where I'd like you
to get your ruler and we're going to
divide this trapezium up from the top
left hand corner all the way to the
bottom right hand corner top left to
bottom rack you do that for me and
please use your ruler
okay now once you've done this diagonal
you can see a trapezium is now made of
two triangles do you see that there's a
top one which is kind of like upside
down and then this bottom one so we can
take them on one at a time this is like
our composite shapes from last time do
you remember that I've got each one and
I'm just going to work them out in turn
so when you have a look at this top
triangle right we've got a formula for
the area of a triangle here what is the
base of this top triangle to be funny
can sub side down right what's the base
it's a very good and the other thing I
need is it's perpendicular height what
is that it's just a H I know it's funny
because H is outside but that's how tall
this skinny triangle is so the area of
that top triangle is 1/2 times the base
which is a times the perpendicular
height which is H very good done that's
the first triangle let's have a look at
the second one it's even easier than the
first it's still a triangle so I'm still
going to use 1/2 base times height
what's the base of the second triangle
should be it's like oh that's the letter
I usually use for the base what's the
perpendicular height of the second
triangle also H these triangles are the
same height so we've got all of our
pieces remember when we were looking at
composite shapes together we said okay
let's tidy this all up by saying the
total area and then we just add the two
things together well here's what I've
got that's the total area and I know
that looks different it looks different
but it's just a bunch of triangles we
can tiny this up a little better though
do you remember we were looking at
algebra back in that topic before we dug
into geometry we said when you've got a
common factor in a bunch of terms you
can pull that common factor out and when
you pull the common factor out what did
we call it when you're looking for a
factor
it's called factorizing right so I'm
gonna factorize these two can someone
tell me something anything that's in
common between those two so here do tell
me one thing H I can
eh both times let's write that out the
front if I factorize that out what do I
get left with there's still a half here
and then an A and then there's another
half and then a B and that tells you
just by reading it out that tells you
there is a second factor I haven't got
yet which is of course altogether a half
thank you very much so I'm gonna go 1/2
H and then what gets left on the inside
a plus B and that if you'd like to put a
box around it is the area of a trapezium
some people like to put the H on top of
the fraction so you might just write
this as H on to a plus B I kind of like
writing the half because it reminds me
that we came from triangles yeah a plus
B divided by H that's an interesting one
maybe a plus B divided by 2 yep
so this half you could write it
underneath the a plus B or you can write
it underneath the H you'd get the same
thing so long as you have all of the
pieces there okay all right so at this
point I'm going to pause I know it does
look different but I'm trying to stress
to you it's come from over here
some of you said I knew this already
that's great I wouldn't do if you could
take the same trapezium literally redraw
the same trapezium see if you can chop
it up a different way to find a
rectangle in there or alternatively draw
the same trapezium and chop it up
another way still and see if you can
find a parallelogram both of those
optional but I challenge all of you guys
to have a go at them